x
dossiers, son statut et
l'argent. Pascal Robidas la
rencontrée à l'hôpital Sainte-
Justine où sont nés ses jumeaux.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pour Mamadi Fara Camara
et de sa conjointe, la vie s'est
adoucie depuis qu'ils sont
les heureux parents de petits
jumeaux, gardés bien au chaud
dans leur incubateur,
au CHU Sainte-Justine.
Merci beaucoup de...
de vous déplacer.
Même si les nuits ont été
courtes, le nouveau papa
de 31 ans affiche un sourire
chaleureux.
- Ah, les bébés vont très bien.
Oui, c'est un garçon
et une fille.
- La naissance de ses enfants,
arrivée quelques semaines
avant la date prévue, marque
un nouveau départ pour celui
qui a été victime d'une grave
erreur judiciaire.
MAMADI FARA CAMARA,
victime d'une erreur judiciaire
- L'arrivée de ces deux enfants,
ça va beaucoup, beaucoup me
réconforter. Ça va beaucoup
repanser un peu la plaie
qui est là.
- Trois mois après avoir été
disculpé dans une enquête
pour la tentative de meurtre
d'un policier du SPVM
dans Parc-Extension, Mamadi Fara
Camara est toujours
en thérapie pour traiter
un choc post-traumatique.
L'ingénieur de formation,
qui est chargé de cours
et technicien de laboratoire,
n'a toujours pas remis les pieds
à Polytechnique.
- Pas encore. J'ai pas repris.
Mais je suis quand même
en contact avec l'École
polytechnique et puis... voilà.
J'espère pouvoir me rétablir
plus rapidement pour pouvoir
recommencer.
- Mamadi Camara suit une
thérapie avec un psychologue.
- Ça avance très bien et...
j'essaie de recommencer à avoir
confiance en moi.
L'École polytechnique m'a fourni
assez de... d'aide, surtout côté
psychologique, et puis
mes avocats aussi. Donc,
j'essaie quand même d'avoir
des rencontres avec eux.
- Mes excuses, je tiens à lui
offrir publiquement.
- Malgré les excuses publiques
du directeur du SPVM, Sylvain
Caron, qui l'a disculpé,
l'homme devient anxieux
lorsqu'il croise des policiers.
- Je peux pas très bien
me promener comme avant.
Quand je rencontre des policiers
ou des agents, j'ai quand même
peur. J'ai réellement peur.
Mais je fais tout mon possible
de ne pas faire de trouble
ou alors de ne pas déranger
pour se faire attraper encore.
Ou autre ch... Donc, je fais
très attention, en fait.
- Les gestes posés par
les policiers lors de son
arrestation le hantent encore.
- Très difficile, très
difficile. Parce que même
un agent à côté de moi,
je me méfie beaucoup. Je...
Vous comprenez. C'est difficile,
quoi. Je me méfie beaucoup.
J'espère que ça va se régler
à l'amiable. Ou alors...
- L'option d'une poursuite
au civil est toujours sur
la table. Mamadi Camara affirme
que ses avocats ont eu
des échanges avec la Ville
de Montréal.
- Vous savez, euh... il y a
quand même un très bon canal
de communication entre eux
et mes avocats. Donc...
Je pense que la procédure suit
son cours.
- Depuis samedi, son statut
d'étudiant étranger est expiré.
Mamadi Camara bénéficie
d'une période de grâce
pour régler son statut
avec Immigration Canada.
- D'octroyer dans les plus brefs
délais la résidence permanente
à Mamadi Fara Camara...
- Trois mois après deux motions
adoptées à l'unanimité à Ottawa
et à Québec pour octroyer
rapidement la résidence
permanente à Mamadi Camara,
le ministre fédéral de
l'Immigration, Marco Mendicino,
n'a visiblement pas utilisé
son pouvoir discrétionnaire
pour régler le dossier.
Malgré les épreuves vécues,
Mamadi Camara, originaire de
Guinée, souhaite que le Québec
devienne sa terre d'accueil.
- Déjà, je peux dire que
les Montréalais, les Québécois,
ils en ont fait beaucoup.
J'ai reçu beaucoup de cadeaux
pour les bébés, avant même leur
naissance. Beaucoup, beaucoup
de cadeaux. Puis, je sais,
ils m'ont vraiment supporté,
je les en remercie pour ça.
- Et quand on lui souhaite
la santé pour lui et sa famille,
il répond...
- Souvent, on dit ça. Moi je dis
pas que c'est la santé avant,
mais c'est la liberté avant.
Ouais. Si tu n'es pas libre,
même si tu es en bonne santé,
c'est pas la peine.
- Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada,